I'm a movie watcher
I'm a movie lover
I have experiences
gazing up at the screen sometimes in
which the performance of an actor can
swallow me whole what I mean by this of
course is that I vanish in the
experience I kind of assume the
Viewpoint of the performer I I
I have an experience in which I believe
them you know they say sometimes fiction
is more truthful than reality but I
believe them and when you believe
someone they become real now I know that
Cinema is a constructed
mind space I know that this is a work of
fiction I know this has been scripted I
know this has been compiled together to
present itself with maximal intensity I
know this is High Fidelity storytelling
I know this is a dramatized performance
piece of Consciousness but nonetheless
sometimes the right performance can
force me to believe they call this
actually the suspension of disbelief and
I'm just fascinated by what exactly
happens to our not just our minds but
the mind of the performer that he can
suspend my disbelief means he too must
have believed what he was reciting and
in this recitation the actor becomes
shamanic the actor as Shaman now I love
movie stars I understand why we all do
they are larger than life they are
living gods they are shamanic they are
ecstatic technicians of the Sacred they
beam something forth
from the space beyond the literal grid
because again
through an act of
hyperspace Alchemy they're able to
suspend my disbelief and I go from a
person sitting in a dark room to being
transported to Nether worlds and
imaginal domains just as real as my real
life experience and so in some senses
the shamanic
the transubstantiation of sorts that
happens on the screen the actor's
performance when they believe and I
believe and we believe catalepsis
happens truth from which nothing can
dislodge us catharsis transformation
healing
this is where Cinema becomes medicine
this is where Cinema becomes Soul Force
this is where cinema this is where
performance becomes
poetry scripture
this is where actors become Church